well thank you for the nice introduction
so the majority of this work was done
jointly with Renata Hahn and Stefan
cider at the Vienna University of
Technology there are some very recent
updates that I included here which
basically is joint work with mature
little off and you want to Dinka at
universities early on so here's the
outline of my talk I'll start with the
standard CSP in which the or talk about
relational constraints and I'll describe
what restrictions and structural
parameters you're looking at and I'll
describe our results and assumptions and
then I discussed the CSP with global
constraints we focus on two types of
constraints the compressed table
constraints and the cardinality
constraints so I'll describe our results
for each type of constraints and I'll
conclude with some open questions mainly
pertaining to CSP with cardinality
constraints okay so we started with the
CSP in which basically the constraints
are relations so an instance of
constraint satisfaction problem is given
as a triple set of variables V instead
of domain values that those variables
can be assigned the values from and the
set of constraints see each constraint
is given as a pair consisting of a
sequence of variables s and the relation
over domain values whose arity matches
the length of s the number of variables
in those so an assignment is a mapping
from the set of variables to domain
values and we say that an assignment
satisfies a constraint if the values
assigned to the variables in this
constraint is a tuple in the relation
off of this constraint and we say that
an assignment satisfies the instance if
it satisfies every constraint in the in
the instance and an instance is
satisfiable if there is a
that satisfies that CSP is the problem
in which we're given an instance and we
asked if there is a satisfying
assignment so here are some of the
restrictions and structural parameters
that we focus on by boolean CSP we do
know the CSP with the boolean domain our
CSP denotes the CSP of bounded era TR
meaning each constraint contains at most
R variables and two poles so this
parameter is gonna denote the total
number of tuples in the in the instance
cancer is gonna do no total number of
constraints
Dom is gonna add in O the domain size
degree is going to denote the maximum
number of constraints any variable
appears in just like in satisfiability
problem and there it is gonna do know
the maximum number of variables any
constraint contains now there are two
kind of popular graphs auxilary graphs
that have been associated with CSP also
with CNF sat the first one is the primal
graph the vertices of this graph are the
variables in the instance and there is
an edge between two vertices if they
occur together in a constraint in the
same constraint the incidence graph is a
bipartite graph and one side you have
the variables and the other side you
have the constraints and there is an
edge between a variable and a constraint
if the variable appears in the
constraint DW denotes the tree width of
the primal graph and TW star denotes the
tree width of the incidence graph okay
so it's obvious to say that a CSP
instance and n variables can be solved
in time domain to the number of
variables by trying all possible
assignments okay so that's like a brute
force trivial algorithm significant work
basically us can start trying to improve
this brute force algorithm they could
only improve in the base of this
exponential term so for example for
certain restrictions like binary CSP you
could do something like domain minus 1
to the number of variables okay but
there's hasn't been any improvement
really in this to bring this linear to
sub-linear basically
so a natural question to ask is can this
exponential term domain size number of
variable reduced be reduced to sub
exponential factor meaning domain too
little of number of variables possibly
considering various natural restrictions
and the CSP problem so this is what we
tried to do try to investigate the sub
exponential time complexity of CSP with
respect to some restrictions and some of
the structural parameters that I already
described earlier and first several of
these parameters we were able to obtain
threshold functions that precisely
dictate when and when not the problem is
solvable in sub exponential time in this
sense that below this threshold function
the problem is so low and sub
exponential time above it it's unlikely
to be sold in some exponential time so
this allows us to kind of draw a
detailed landscape of this sub
exponential time complexity of CSP with
respect to those restrictions and the
structure parameters that we consider
imperative similar work for CNF South
like in terms of the clause density or
frequency or the width of the clauses
stuff like that now most of our negative
or lower bound results are derived under
common assumptions in complexity theory
such as ETH does not fail W hierarchy
does not collapse at a certain level and
CNF South is not so in some exponential
time so to kind of translate some of
this lower bound results for that we
already know for CNF south we kind of
establish a connection or reductions
from CNF South's restrictions of CNF
start to CSP and restrictions of CSP so
this allows us again to translate some
of the lower bound results that we
already know for CNF sad to CSP so
naturally CSP seems a more general
problem that saying upset in the sense
that an obvious way of modeling CNF set
as a CSP is to look at every clause and
model the clause as a constraint
containing all the tuples or the values
that are basically
assigned to the variables of the clauses
that satisfy the clause okay so that's a
natural way of looking at CNF sat as a
CSP problem okay
so using this kind of a trivial you know
modeling we immediately can obtain the
following results the theorem is stated
in terms of boolean but it could be
stated in terms of any bounded domain
size so basically the theorem says that
the sub exponential time complexity of
boolean bounded air to CSP is basically
the same as the sub exponential time
complexity sk CNF Sat so you could solve
this problem in sub exponential time if
and only if ETH fails okay and again by
for any bounded domain size the same
result holds true by encoding the domain
size using binary variables you can see
that so this is a very easy to see on if
on one basically direction if you look
at let's say look at 3-cnf start right
then again every clause because it has
with at most three can be modeled as a
constraint and you can enumerate all the
tuples that satisfy it in constant time
basically so you could transform an
instance of three saying I've set an
instance of CSP on the same number of
variables basically and that's like a
polynomial time stress reduction okay
on the other hand also because you have
bounded domain size and bounding the
arity you could take every constraint
and encode it using you know a constant
number of 3-cnf clauses okay and it's
still using the same set of variables so
this gives you both directions it's very
easy to see now what we've shown is if
you drop the bound on the domain size so
you allow unbound the domain size but
keep basically the upper bound on the
arity even if you consider basically
binary CSP then we give evidence that
the problem now seemed to become hotter
in the sense that if you could solve
binary CSP and sub-exponential time then
you could solve clique and time and
little okay so of course if clique is an
N little of K this implies that ETH
fails okay
the other direction is not known and
basically it's not believed to be true
so now if you on the other hand if you
look at boolean cSPD so bounded
basically domain size but allow
unbounded arity so what we could show is
the following result if you could solve
boolean CSP in none your from sub
exponential time then you can solve CNF
sat and not your phone
sub exponential time now why is this non
uniformity here well again if you we
said that CSP seems to be more general
than seeing outside but the problem
really is in the representation of CSP
because if you take a clause and CNF
side and you want to basically encode it
as a constraint then you need to
enumerate all tuples that satisfy this
clause
now if the width of this clause is
linear in n then to enumerate all tuples
you need exponential time so if you're
trying to achieve a sub exponential surf
reduction from CNF side to CSP or to
boolean CSP you cannot afford to you
know enumerated tuples however what you
could do is you could start by applying
a branching algorithm due to Schiller
that reduces the width of each clause
from possibly linear to if you have
linear with Clause 2 sub linear okay and
then after reducing it to sub linear now
you could basically enumerate all tuples
but in order for this branching
algorithm by shoulder to kind of run in
sub exponential time you need to know
that the number of clauses is somehow
sub-exponential if the number of clauses
in the CNF instance is exponential let's
say larger than 2 to some C times n
where does see now there's a relation
between the sub exponential time that
you're trying to achieve in this C then
you could afford in that case if it's
number of call sub-exponential to run
shoulders algorithm then basically model
each Clause as a constraint and
everything will go through however if
the number of clauses is exponential
then you cannot afford doing that but in
this case what you know is if you use
the brute force algorithm the
the instance size is exponential in M
then this brute-force algorithm would
run basically in polynomial time in the
instance size however that polynomial
the exponent of that polynomial depends
on the epsilon that you're trying to
achieve so that's why for every epsilon
you're trying to achieve you get a
different polynomial basically and this
is hence the non-uniformity in this this
reduction so this is what we could show
in this case okay so kind of to just
summarize or highlight the results that
we obtained for CSP with respect to the
different structural parameters that we
looked at so here in blue you have the
positive results and red you have the
negative the negative results are under
the assumption that eth does not fail so
we could show if the number of tuples is
sub linear then the problem is all in
sub exponential time if it's linear it's
not if the number of constraints is
constant the problem can be easily shown
to be impedes known to be NP if the
number of constraints is a little Omega
of 1 it's not solvable in sub
exponential time the degree is one of
the problems in p degree greater or
equal to two the problem is not sold on
sub exponential time for arity if the
earthly is one or if the earth is two
and the domain is at most two the
problem is known to be in P otherwise
it's not so low and sub exponential time
in terms of the primal tree with if the
primal tree with is sub linear the
problem is solving some exponential time
if it's linear it's not if the incidence
tree with is a constant the problem is
in P if it's omega fun the problem is
not so low in sub exponential time so
this is basically a summary of the
results that we obtained for the
standard ok so now I kind of moved to
talk about the CSP with global
constraints so in the CSP the
constraints are given extension ly as
tables or relations in CSP with global
constraints the constraints are
specified intentionally using some
property basically that you need to
satisfy in order for the constraint to
be satisfied now we consider two main
categories
of global constraints the first category
is cardinality constraints and there are
different types that we consider we have
the CSP with all different constraints
that we do not CSP different CSP with
exactly and value constraint we do not
ESP equal at least and value it says
bigger equal at most n value CSP doesn't
really hold and also for several of our
results you could allow a combination of
of those constraints and the other
category that we consider is CSP with
compressed table constraints CSP C I'm
gonna describe what those who are so and
CSU global constrained the goal remains
to find an assignment that satisfies all
the constraints but satisfying now oh it
constraint takes a different meaning so
for this SP all different it constraint
is satisfied if its variables are
assigned distinct values for this SP
equals SP less than or equals SP greater
or equal each constraint is given
together with a non-negative integer and
C and the CSP equal constraint is
satisfied if the number of distinct
values is assigned to its variable is
exactly this number NC and the less than
or equal to constraint is satisfied if
the number of distinct values assigned
to its variable is that most NC and CSP
where equal it constraint is satisfied
if the number of distinct value is at
least NC or CSP with compress tables
constraint there is given again as a
pair consisting of a sequence of
variables and compressed set of
compressed tuples each compress tuple is
a sequence of subsets of domains of
these variables so v1 is a subset of
domain values of variable V 1 V R is a
subset of domain values of the arm and
the constraint is satisfied if it's
variables are assigned values that
basically that correspond to a tuple and
the cross-product of one of these
compressed tuples so you could kind of
decompress if you want each one of those
compressed suppose to obtain a table and
now you have basically the CSP
back in this case now it's known that
all those aforementioned CSPs global
constraints are np-complete some of them
are even np-complete for one constraint
in even when you have one constraint so
why do we consider CSP with global
constraints first they seem to be very
important in practice so they do model
many np-hard problems and the reason why
they're important in practice especially
you know people use combinations of
those because it kind of gives you a
more compact representation of these
these constraints so for instance this
CSP would compress table can potentially
provide exponential reduction in the
size because really you're reducing you
know the cross product or all the
islands and cross products so now if you
could represent them as basically the
sum of the cardinality is as opposed to
the product of basically the cardinality
here
now those CSP with cardinality
constraints on the other hand they are
naturally model many graph problems
graph coloring problems so the CSP with
all different constraints even if you
look at the binary OCSP all different
constraints it can model graph coloring
and in general you could model different
types of hyper graph coloring problem
where you are you wanna say for each
hyper edge I want it to be assigned
exactly this many colors or as vertices
to be called exactly this many colors or
at least this many colors or at most
this many colors so then naturally model
many of those coloring problems as
you'll see shortly okay so start by
highlighting some of the tight results
that we get for CSP with the compressed
table constraints and then we move to
the other CSPs global constraint
resource history of cardinality
constraints so clearly this CSP was
compressed table is a generalization of
CSP you could look at CSP as a CSP with
compressed tables in which basically
each one of those sets of the main
values as a singleton okay and for CSP
we already saw
that we know if boolean Cespedes ovens
have exponential time of course ETH
failed but we also say that if it's sold
well in non-uniform sub-exponential time
then CNF South is so low in onion for
some explanation time so we do have such
results already for boolean someone can
ask what do what can we say now about
the boolean CSP with compress table so
we kind of give evidence that it's
harder than boolean CSP what we show is
if you could solve boolean CSP with
compress table and sub exponential time
then the W hierarchy collapses at the
second level of course this result W to
equal F BT implies that CNF sat is in
some exponential
sub exponential time now in terms of
again the results that we get with
respect to those structural parameters
described earlier we got actually a
table that more or less matches the
table that I showed you earlier for CSP
so all these results seem to kind of
carry over here without really any
major changes okay so now we move to
those CSP with the cardinality
constraints and we start with the CSP
with all different constraints so again
recall here that it all different
constraint is satisfied if all the
variables receive distinct values in the
in the constraint so you could easily
see that the problem can be modeled as a
list coloring problem where the vertices
of the graph are the variables of the
instance and the each vertex is its list
of colors is basically the values and
its domain and now two vertices are
adjacent if they appear together in the
scope of the same constraint this gives
us basically a simple reduction from CSP
all different to list coloring now we
know that list coloring is solvable in
time two to the N so this tells you that
CSP all different is all boolean time 2
to the N direct consequence of this is
that if you look at any domain size
that's little Omega of 1 then you can
say that CSP all different is sold in
some exponential time in this case
because 2 to the N is becomes domain to
the little off and if the domain is
Omega of 1 so this tells you for any
domain size that's not a constant the
problem solver in some exponential time
so now you could focus really on
constant size domain if the domain is 2
then the problem is known to be in P in
this case so you can look at them in
greater than 2 and just highlight some
of the tight results again that we get
in this case so for domain again that's
little Omega of 1 the problem is
trivially in sub-exponential time by
this list coloring reduction and if the
domain is greater equal to 3 it's not in
sub exponential time under ETH now the
number of constraint is linear it's not
in some exponential time in this case
because the domain size as I mentioned
is bounded it doesn't make sense to
consider the number of constraint to be
sub linear because if the domain size is
bounded
then the earth is bounded because you're
looking at all different which implies
basically that you need a linear number
of constraints to account for all the
variables in the instance so if the
primal tree width is sub linear the
problem is in sub exponential time if
it's linear it's not same thing holds
for the incidence tree of all right so
with respect to the remaining
cardinality constraints well we could
show again it's the tight results that
we could show is in terms of the primal
tree width if kind of the same results
for all different hold true here if the
primal tree with is sub linear the
prominence of exponential time if it's
linear it's not and finally with respect
to the number of constraints we could
show that all these problems are
unlikely to be in sub exponential time
again under ETH when the number of
constraints is linear and the domain
size is is constant
on the other hand if the number of
constraints is sub linear then all these
problems are so low and sub exponential
time and this is some of the variations
result that we obtained here use kind of
dynamic programming to get this
exponential time algorithm ok so just
want to conclude with some open
questions really that are related to
these two theorems here and also to some
of the some of the earlier discussions
here at the workshop mainly to the talk
given by Fodor women the first the first
day of the conference so again for this
cardinality constraints we show that if
the number of constraint is sub linear
the problem-solver and sub exponential
time but now if the number of
constraints is linear the only hardness
results that we could show is when the
domain size is is constant underneath eh
because really you could reduce 3
colorability here to this problem in
this case together
I think the interesting questions here
that remain here regarding this this
topic is what happens if the domain size
is not a constant and the number of
constraints is now linear okay so in
particular what if you talked about a
number of constraints that's linear and
the domain size that's linear so now the
problem really is like you're assigning
these end variables to you know domain
values and the size of the domain is
linear so we have this mapping from
linear size to linear size and you have
also a linear or at least a linear
number of constraints where you could
encode basically used to encode problems
with can you still get a sub exponential
time in this case or on the other hand
can use some of those recent lower bound
results built on graph morphism because
you could see maybe you could try to
model graph homomorphism using you know
these kind of cardinality constraints
CSP here to get a lower bound result but
the difficulty sees is those cardinality
constraints they're kind of restrictive
and what you could use what you could
encode with so if you try to encode a
graph a morphism problem at least from
the you know first attempts that we
tried you kind of end up increasing the
number of variables to you know
quadratic so you don't get a short
reduction so I think a natural question
here just to either basically show that
still can do some exponential time in
this case or try to kind of under a th
maybe rule out the possibility for
larger domain size okay so that
concludes my talk thank you for
listening
questions
you know Huxley's result I think so 2014
I think he used a different
representation for CSP not the standard
representation I believe he is like a
DNF representation of CSP yeah it's a
different way of representing CSP yes if
I basically forgot what you're talking
about yeah
lots of dumb or linear Andy do you
expect it to be so the exponential or
not actually I don't know it could go
really either way I mean I don't know I
don't have a strong feeling about about
this I mean this this cardinality
constraints seem to be again very
restrictive when you try to encode
problem with because you just say well
this constraint I need to assign at
least this many distinct values so like
we tried to encode graph a morphism with
them but we couldn't maybe there is a
kind of a clever dynamic programming
algorithm or you could still get some
exponential time in this square when
both the number of constraint is N and
the domain size is n we don't have again
any end result that was like an open
question of whether you can do sub
exponential time in this case or not
so some exponential in this case when
both are linear is n little o of M
you're asking can I do n little o of n
when the number of constraints is linear
and domain sizes is when you're this is
what I'm saying maybe you could use this
lower bound on graph polymorphism to say
under ETH I cannot get a little off and
in this case
thank you